today's topic anna mclaughlin alright so
if you guys are unaware anna mclana is a
trans mma fighter pre-transition was
anna was a soldier with the u.s special
forces she trained in mixed martial arts
recently she competed after going
through transition surgery for some time
she competed against a female named
celine provost sit in provo
by submission after a little over three
minutes in miami last week and after a
victory
she donned a t-shirt which said in
transgenocide posted a little photo
saying good morning friends supporters
and others i'm getting a lot of
variations the same nasty messages
calling me a cheater like i didn't just
get beat on forehead for a round and a
half you all need to show sit in provo
some respect and take your concerns and
trolling elsewhere oh my god did you
hear about the story yeah what did you
think when you first saw it
next we've been over this
there's nothing new that i'm going to be
able to say about that there's nothing
new i'm going to be able to add to this
nothing
nothing i haven't said nothing new it's
gonna be the same thing over and over
so
i didn't really look into it to be
honest with you what i wanted to know
was the outcome of the fight i knew the
outcome of the fight and i went
yeah yeah
you're right i went next you got the
right take at the end of the day
you know
we're not going to bring up the bone
density the research all the stuff we're
not going to bring up the unfair
advantages because you guys have heard
it we all know it okay so at this point
we're beyond that and at some point
things get redundant and you just start
repeating things for clicks and views so
we're not going to do that
my stains at this point is ladies got to
take up this mantle and do the fighting
for it ladies got to be the ones who say
something you know because it coming
from two heteronormative straight men
blah blah blah it's gonna come always
across a lot funnier ladies got to be
the ones to fight for their homes
they got to import those boycotts they
got to say we're not going to accept
if they if they really feel strongly
about this and if they don't then listen
let the trans women come in and wreck
the sports i don't
it's not my place to do it at the end of
the day you guys have most to lose so it
should be you guys speaking about this
more than anybody oh
interesting
go ahead no because a couple of videos
ago i said exactly that he said i was
strolling
i said exactly that you're trolling i'm
like no bro
what do you want us to do it's going in
that direction you know what i mean and
at the same time at the end of the day
we never had a spot in this conversation
never it was not us to have that
conversation so why would we you're
gonna bust your balls and then get [ __ ]
around for something if they that's
exactly that well i mean listen there's
two sides of the conversation is what
you said and then the other side which
is you know the other day it's going to
be women whose lives are going to be in
danger as a result of this happening i
understand but it's not my place to say
because i never had a [ __ ] place to
say and it's already been said it's
already said here's the count argument
to that go ahead let's say it's your
daughter or sister they're competing in
mma they say no they don't accept having
to fight a trans person the commission
says well these are the rules in place
don't you think you should be adding
your voice to your daughters or sisters
i can only talk to my daughter why can't
she talk publicly
because it doesn't i don't i don't know
how my
me saying something whether i'm the
father or a man or the boyfriend is
going to add anything to this because
i'm going to say the same thing right
and it's anyone i know you know what you
know what actually
and i'm not saying that because i don't
have a daughter i'm just saying that
because
that's why i understand the world works
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] until my
daughter dies
and even when she is
because she got beat up in that mma
fight whatever people are gonna move on
that's what happens that's what keeps on
happening
are the rules changing no because we
want to do the righteous thing so nobody
cares about me or my potential daughter
that's gonna do mma nobody cares nobody
cares
so shouldn't you be fighting regardless
that's not what i'm saying i'm just
saying i don't know what proof that i
have so i can only i can only i have
just
that much energy so i'm just gonna
concentrate on my daughter i'm just
going to be concentrating on you know
what there's this and that i'm going to
give all my energy to my daughter not
all the rest of the people at the end of
the day my daughter if she she competes
in mma she's a grown adult too and she's
going to be able to make her decision i
can employ you know you have parents
that implore you to not do anything not
do this not do that what you do you go
and you do your own experience and you
break your face
so yeah yeah listen my my issue
personally is like i just don't care
enough about this issue
to be honest with y'all i think it's a
fun talking point i think it's an
interesting thing i do think it's unfair
but i don't really care care i don't if
i'm being very honest
i don't i like watching women's mma if
it's on a good ufc court i'll watch it
you know i mean shout out to to thug
rose do i really care not really
be honest and so that's probably why i
won't cover this topic again in the
future because i don't care that deeply
it's not going to change anything bro i
mean listen most of the videos we do
don't change anything fair so i don't
think that's a precursor to whether or
not you should talk about something but
it's
my my indifference you know it really
comes from it's not that we can't do
anything or you know
i don't care enough
that's the truth
so maybe i'm [ __ ] up and maybe you
guys are disappointed by that maybe you
guys wanted me to voice whatever outrage
but the truth is after you cover this
four or five times and use the same
[ __ ] arguments and people don't call
them on it enough or maybe they do they
just don't care at some point i'm like
well listen the information's out there
if they want to believe it they do and
they don't they don't and i'm just not
yelling anybody i'm not going to get
upset i'm like yeah
it's like whenever it's like you know
whenever you're exposed to something
enough you don't care yeah
the first school shooting
yeah i was
borderline traumatized i was like oh
snap yeah i'll get you on that when
columbine happened bruh
i was like whoa
nick pulley technique happened i was
like seven i was like whoa right but
then after a while
i get you
man get you man
so so you ask us about this topic
potatoes potatoes
[Music]
foreign